i
[Música]
maratón diplomática del presidente
francés emmanuel marco tras su reunión
ayer con el presidente ruso vladimir
putin hoy estuvo en kiev y en alemania
para intentar desescalar las tensiones
tenemos análisis en esta emisión
hay protestas en buenos aires contra el
acuerdo entre el presidente de alberto
fernández y el fondo monetario
internacional los supositorios rechazan
la reestructuración de la deuda que
pactó y que el congreso aún no aprueba
tenemos información desde la capital
argentina
ya se conocen los nominados para la
edición número 94 de los premios oscar
la película the power of the dog de
netflix es la que más postulaciones
tiene al ser candidata en 12 categorías
[Música]
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es maría
clara calle y es un placer saludarlos y
comenzamos en kiev donde el presidente
de manuel ma hope se reunió con el
mandatario ucraniano volodymyr selenski
un día después de haber viajado a moscú
para dialogar con su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin todo con el objetivo de
disminuir las tensiones entre ambos
países generadas por el despliegue de
tropas rusas en la frontera bajo afirmó
que putin se comprometió a no escalar
las crisis fronterizas aunque el kremlin
negó que hayan logrado un acuerdo por lo
que se le en esquí sostiene que no
confía escuchemos a los mandatarios
sobre las discusiones sobre aspectos
militares y de seguridad
como dije muy claramente ayer hemos
tenido intercambio con el presidente
putin y él me dijo que no estaría detrás
de ninguna escalada
en general no confío mucho en las
palabras por eso creo que todo político
puede mostrar su apertura con hechos
concretos en nuestro caso esos son pasos
hacia la des escalada de escaladas
para hacer esto según tengo entendido
esta persona está abierta esta persona
tiene posibilidades
del azzurro child in say yeah
y luego más como continuó su gira
diplomática en berlín y allí se reunió
con el canciller alemán olaf scholz y
con el presidente de polonia andrzej
duda el mandatario francés sostuvo que
el deber de los líderes europeos es
evitar la guerra y alemania respaldó la
postura agregando que el objetivo es
mantener la paz a través de la
diplomacia escuchemos los
seguiremos actuando en las próximas
semanas con objetivos simples el primero
se ha dicho es evitar la guerra jr la
pelea la paz y la estabilidad del
continente europeo son nuestro tesoro y
consideramos que debemos hacer todo para
preservarlo
fayt una violación de la integridad
territorial y la soberanía de ucrania es
inaceptable y tendrá consecuencias de
gran alcance para rusia política
económica y ciertamente también
geoestratégicamente
y para analizar la gira diplomática del
presidente de manuel majo está con
nosotros eugeni y richard investigadora
de la universidad externado de colombia
bienvenida a france 24 y empecemos
hablando de macrón envía hoy un mensaje
de unión junto a sus homólogos de
alemania y polonia en este sentido se
puede decir que fue un error ir ayer a
moscú no no no no ha sido un error
manuel mantiene una relación
privilegiada con putin ya se habían
encontrado varias veces piensa que puede
lograr un gesto concreto por parte del
presidente ruso aunque la política
exterior de majón puede parecer un
poquito inocente mccomb piensa que ahí
puede imponer un poquito su leadership
natural de francia para lograr un
acuerdo en esta crisis y obviamente así
ganar visibilidad tanto en la escena
internacional como marcar puntos también
en la política interior francesa y usted
menciona precisamente la política
interior francesa se podría decir
entonces que el recorrido de macrón
podría tener motivos para mover su o en
el año electoral de francia en este
momento claro que si podemos decir que
el activismo diplomático de mayo se usa
como un arma digamos de política
interior que va a servir para impulsar
su candidatura a su propia reelección
que tendrá lugar el 10
y también permite a makoun dar una
dimensión internacional a su candidatura
e imponerse frente a sus contricantes
franceses que no gozan digamos de stay
leadership natural que tiene bajo en la
escena internacional no olvidemos que
francia tiene la presencia desde el
primero de enero de la unión europea
entonces macon quiere aprovechar este
espacio internacional también para
reafirmar su liderazgo dentro de las
encuestas para la elección del próximo
creciente y a propósito este espacio
internacional que usted menciona como
ayuda en estas giras a la posición de
francia en el mundo
bueno makoun quiere imponerse como el
líder ahora el gran líder de la unión
europea no olvidemos entonces que angela
markel ya salió
franco-alemán era como el motor de la
unión europea ahora mca es el que queda
es la figura más visible digamos del
líder si al nivel de la unión europea
entonces intenta aprovechar esta crisis
ucraniana para reforzar digamos la idea
de que francia es el un uno de los
países motores de la unión europea y que
aquí tiene una posición de autoridad y
de liderazgo privilegiado para resolver
este tipo de crisis y proyectar el país
como un líder natural en el espacio
europeo el fin y richard gracias por
estar con nosotros ahora vamos a
argentina en buenos aires hay protestas
en contra del acuerdo que alcanzó el
gobierno de alberto fernández con el
fondo monetario internacional para
refinanciar la deuda de más de 40 mil
millones de dólares nuestro corresponsal
natalio cosoi nos cuenta qué pasó
miles de personas marchan hacia la plaza
de mayo en esta convocatoria de
organizaciones y partidos de izquierda
en contra de un eventual acuerdo con el
fondo monetario
internacional a fines de enero el
presidente alberto fernández dijo que se
había alcanzado un principio de acuerdo
con el organismo para refinanciar unos
44 mil millones de dólares de deuda que
había tomado el ex presidente mauricio
macri esto es porque el país tiene
serias dificultades para enfrentar los
pagos de esa deuda que se vienen a lo
largo de 2022 y en los próximos años el
presidente alberto fernández dijo que
este era el mejor acuerdo que se podía
lograr pero quienes están aquí no están
de acuerdo dicen que la deuda es
ilegítima que no corresponde pagar la
que no hay que pagarla y que un acuerdo
terminaría llevando un ajuste del estado
que impactaría sobre los sectores más
vulnerables de argentina en todo caso
será el congreso de la nación el que
deba decir si aprueba o no un eventual
acuerdo un congreso donde la izquierda
no tiene los suficientes números como
para vetarlo por sí mismo
y hay sectores de la coalición
gobernante del frente de todos que se
han mostrado en desacuerdo y no está
claro todavía si lo votarán a favor o en
contra
al menos 14 personas murieron en el
centro de colombia en la madrugada de
este martes las lluvias produjeron un
deslizamiento de tierra en el
departamento de risaralda el reporte más
reciente es que también hubo 35 heridos
y una persona sigue desaparecida además
15 familias fueron evacuadas ante el
peligro uno no puede decir mayor cosa
porque él no se sintió el cimbronazo y
se vino todo encima y uno se la pasa
buscando los familiares a mi papá hasta
ahí no se sabe si está vivo esto era el
inquilinato todo esto el señor de la
tienda murió varias personas murieron ya
se conocen los nominados de los premios
oscar la academia de las artes y las
ciencias cinematográficas de eeuu
publicó sus postulaciones para la
edición número 94 a la cabeza de los
aspirantes están el western gótico the
power of the dog con 12 nominaciones y
la épica de ciencia ficción dunn con 10
el líder de la manada de power of the
dog olfatea la gloria de los oscar la
oscura meditación de jane campion sobre
la masculinidad tóxica y la sexualidad
prohibida ambientada en un rancho
ganadero de montana de los años 20 fue
producida por netflix
ahora aspira 12 premios de la academia
incluido el de mejor película nacida en
nueva zelanda campeonas e historia como
la primera mujer en ser nominada dos
veces a mejor dirección 28 años después
de su anterior nominación por el piano
la extensa y atmosférica adaptación de
la clásica novela de ciencia ficción de
frank herbert ha conseguido 10
nominaciones aunque ninguna para el
director canadiense de nivel nerd
la adaptación de steven spielberg del
reconocido musical 'west side story'
obtuvo siete nominaciones al igual que
belfast la historia autobiográfica el
director kenneth branagh sobre su
crecimiento durante el conflicto
norirlandés convirtiendo a plena fe en
la única persona en la historia de los
oscar con siete nominaciones en siete
categorías diferentes a lo largo de su
carrera a
los oscar de este año marcan la
continuación de la batalla por el
prestigio entre los estudios
tradicionales y los servicios de
streaming con dos nominaciones a la
mejor película para las producciones de
netflix y una para apple tv y aunque los
nominados representan orígenes más
diversos que las listas de 2015 y 2016
que desataron el hashtag oscar show
white las nominaciones de este año son
notablemente menos inclusivas que el año
pasado cuando 9 de las 20 nominaciones
de actuación fueron para personas de
color
sigan con nosotros
[Música]